[Music]
so you discuss the difficulties as a
health care provider hot environment
protective clothing that is heavy and
you dehydrated and so you can only work
one to one-half hours at a stretch how
difficult does that make the
interpersonal contact with patients and
just the technical ability to do things
like put in a intravenous syringe right
it's very challenging obviously I mean
we the clinicians and I think most of
the staff that works in the 80s will do
their best to try to engage with
patients in in a way that is meaningful
so basic things like writing your name
on the above your goggles for patients
could identify you I mean this became a
big part of it just people were so
afraid being infected being stuck in an
e tu watching their loved ones and died
around them and terrifying so this
became a big very real practice to the
clinician this was to try to provide
some human familiarity contact with the
patients how many terms of doing
procedures it's incredibly challenging
and double gloves you're dripping sweat
from every pore people are hypovolemic I
mean this is incredibly challenging but
you do your best you try to find a big
vein you you don't attempt until you
feel comfort
all I mean it's incredibly challenging
so so some appointed to the fact that
the survival rates were so much higher
in people who contracted Ebola or were
flown to europe or the UK or the US you
know the numbers are a couple of
handfuls but it's been said that if
those facilities were available
mortality rate case fatality rate could
have been so much lower is it really
realistic to imagine that that could
have been provided at short notice and
the ability to lower the case fatality
rate could have been put in place with
more modern or more sophisticated et use
supported from abroad you know I again
it's a visceral part this question I
mean I think what we know about what we
have learned from this outbreak is that
factors that really contribute to
mortality include viral load at time of
presentation and age I think so that's
that's one part of it and then
accounting for other things like
comorbidities in so in the patients that
were infected and then expatriated which
were taken back to the u.s. to the UK
and it's I think what is important to
remember is that they received a variety
of interventions everything from
mechanical ventilation to hemodialysis
to a cocktail of various experimental
therapies it is hard to know exactly
which of those interventions combined
with aid communities viral load impacted
their outcomes the second part of it is
in the midst of an outbreak to be able
to
were implement very sophisticated
medical devices is it is very very
challenging I'm in the peak of the
outbreak there was just the need to do
very basic things like to provide enough
etu beds I think yes optimistically we
would say you know for worn before armed
and I think having things in place like
point-of-care tests really simple basic
tools that can be used in a more
widespread way in a tus would perhaps
[Music]
perhaps help have self change outcomes
in future outbreaks if there are future
outbreaks things like more invasive
means to deliver intravenous or
intraosseous resuscitation these of I
know drugs mechanical ventilation I mean
some of these things I think perhaps can
be implemented some of these things are
I think not realistic in the peak of an
outbreak again weighing up safety as the
safety and feasibility in an e tu
setting i think is needs to be
considered before we talk in more detail
about more sophisticated mechanical
tools to say nothing about electricity
and exciting and the other factors that
you'd need the ETU you have patience
you've now got a four hour turnaround on
the test how does one handle triage of
who arrives who should be brought to the
unit who should be admitted and how you
deal with people with non abola
conditions but who are in urgent acute
need of medical care so there is a fair
system emergency and the decision to
admit someone to the suspect tent is
really based on an assessment of risk so
see the plus essentially exposure anyone
with so anyone that needs that triage
admission criteria would get admitted to
the suspect tent more tense they would
then if they had been symptomatic for
greater than 72 hours they would have a
PCR test with a four hour turnaround
time that would concern yes or no they
were infected if they were infected they
would go into the concern intent
everyone that was admitted to the ETU
wouldn't curricle e get broad spectrum
antibiotics and anti-malarials to try to
combat other common infectious diseases
that may cause fever so that was
standard practice in a tu and people
arriving with other treatable or social
conditions just have to be turned away
because you're focused on one single
disease that's right so this is part of
the complexity and one of the hardest
things in fact is the people that have
other clinical problems pregnant women I
mean this is the one of the most tragic
parts of at least in my time in Liberia
was seeing pregnant women present who
had been turned away from multiple other
hospitals because they were several
they'd had exposure to Ebola so the
concern was of course that they were
infected and to have any sort of
intervention with an associated enormous
transmission risk was not manageable
in most of the healthcare facilities in
Liberia at least the time that I was
there and did that pre-exists the
epidemic or did those hospitals
essentially close or fail to function
because of the diabolo so I think it's
all the latter I mean once again these
are countries that don't have
particularly strong health systems to
start with you layer on top of that the
really the panic in the fear associated
with acquiring a bowler treating
patients with Ebola your transmission to
others healthcare in the country was
essentially just shut down there were a
few functioning facilities there was a
referral hospital that we could refer
patients to but for many many many monks
health care facilities that were not et
use were completely in shutdown and this
is a disease for which may be one of the
iris groups healthcare workers i believe
about 500 of the 11,000 people who died
were healthcare workers so that impacts
just the number of people available to
help and what's the psychological impact
for a healthcare worker of knowing that
and knowing that risk I think I can't
speak for everybody i think it's you i
think people reacting very people's
experiences i think have been quite
varied at least the people that I know
and and continue to be in contact with
that worked in ambala sitting in this
most recent outbreak in their their
responses have been really across the
spectrum for some people it's been
incredibly challenging and for others
say has that continued and it's been
it's just been completely manageable I
think of course there is a concern of
acquiring the disease of fear of course
I mean met on some frontier was with
very clear about rules and regulations
in the field to try to to minimize risk
and try to mitigate that fear at least
within our health care what good so
you've been in other digital places with
NSF you know how is this different from
working in other crises I have never
quite experienced the level of fear and
again I can't speak for everybody but
the the level of panic I have never
really experienced before in any setting
I have never seen patients looks so
afraid or be so afraid I I think that's
probably the biggest thing is the fear
of infection of even even the smallest
contact with with people things that we
take for granted every day like shaking
hands just completely absent and I mean
I've worked had worked in HIV for some
years before the only thing that I can
possibly liken this to is perhaps the
bad old days the early days of HIV
exactly is for treatment the other thing
that I think is has been disturbing
about this is the rapidity of
deterioration of patients hours to days
as opposed to
months